my folks my people thank you once again
for clicking on my face you know one of
the reasons for my videos other than
giving you my thoughts on a movie or
entertainment in general is to prep you
for the movie without spoiling the movie
you know to let you know what you can
expect when watching the movie this
movie though
have you ever tried salvia
[Music]
oh i still have warhammer paint on my
finger i'm not flipping you off i'm
saying
right so everything everywhere all at
once is directed by the daniels of swiss
army man fame stars michelle yo she's a
mom she's a wife her and her family run
this laundry mat their taxes are also
being audited by an auditor played by
jamie curtis i thought she was great in
the movie as well also you ever see a
joke and then the movie actually takes
the joke it's not just a visual that
happens in here because those we all
knew
those are not awards those are not
trophies they don't go on your desk they
go in your trunk but basically the
consciousness of her husband from
another dimension another reality
another universe inhabits her husband's
body that's how it works in here it's
not like you go into another reality and
there's physically two of you know your
consciousness goes into the body of
another you in another universe and you
have all their memories ergo their
skills that's very important in this
movie basically alternate husband of
hers is like hey there's a multiverse
and there's this person who has
basically become a multiverse god very
terrifying also coming to kill you but
also you're the only one who can defeat
this multiverse god so good luck i'm
gonna help you out and now we have
ourselves a very grounded down-to-earth
fun multiverse adventure and i thought
everyone in this movie did a great job
michelle yo was a great lead a
sympathetic character who has been
called upon for this hero's quest
adventure man is just like that's
fundamental i mean she's in 99 of the
scenes in this movie for she carries it
ki hai kwan plays her husband stephanie
sue i hope i get the names right i'm
[ __ ] with names you all know that at
this point if you don't know that
welcome to my channel thank you for
clicking they were great stephanie sue
was a standout in this movie she's one
where
there's a lot required of her just
emotionally speaking and i thought she
really worked and how they deal with the
multiverse in this movie i thought was
remarkably imaginative it's not just oh
hey you have a device and now you're
there it's there are things they have to
do
at first it's this quirky weird thing
that i'm like why are they doing that
and the movie explains it i don't want
to tell you because the fun is having
the movie
walk you through this path walk you
through the story but when it explains
it i was like
that makes a remarkable amount of sense
to me in a world where anything that can
happen will happen you see some
ridiculous stuff in this movie but for
the most part some crazy ridiculous
stuff you see in this movie is within
context of the movie and it has fun with
these concepts there's one fight
sequence in particular i was like this
fight looks like a fight from a jackass
movie all i can say about it that said
everything that's happening on screen is
within context of the movie and there is
an interesting message in here about
nihilism they're doing with the villain
i mean it can be argued that we of the
pale blue dot don't matter in the cosmic
scheme of things which i think is a
healthy thing to ponder meditate on it
makes you feel like your problems here
on earth are more manageable because
they don't matter in the cosmic scheme
of thing but at what point can a person
become essentially a god and truly not
give a [ __ ] granted is touched on other
entertainment like watchmen but this one
had an emotional weight to it with the
character that really surprised me i
suppose one of the things i love most
about this movie is it's not that the
movie elevated its genre because i don't
think you can box this movie into a
genre it has exciting action sequences
but the movie's not an action movie it
has really interesting multiverse
traversal but it's not a sci-fi movie to
its core it's actually a very
surprisingly touching family drama that
holds this whole thing together that was
an amazing surprise in this film didn't
expect it love to see it as much as
there were quirky things in this movie
that completely worked for the concept
and the execution of the movie not
everything stuck the landing for me it's
usually dealing with hot dogs and bagels
i was like that's that's what you're
going with i don't know what it was
about hot dogs i was like that's
that is weird i just want to bite
through a finger and then it grosses me
out because i'm like ah it's like a raw
hot dog
yeah
it's just one of those visuals i was
like i don't like it is that a personal
taste thing
yeah in the end everything everywhere
all at once is one of those movies it's
one of those theatrical experiences i
walked out of and i was like
i don't think i'm going to forget that
movie anytime soon it's quirky fun and
ridiculous in a lot of ways that work in
which a lot of other filmmakers out
there wouldn't have been able to make it
work do you make the argument if you're
looking for a very unique movie going
experience you'd be hard-pressed to find
one this unique and enjoyable because
the movie can be unique but just not
land with you it's happened to all of us
so i'll be serious about it there's that
movie out there people are praising and
you watch it and you're like
how about that weather right right it's
happened to all of us i do not think you
should miss this one and in the spirit
of this film let's make a couple
different timelines of our own heads
it's awesome tacular tails buy it on
blu-ray here we go
and it turns out everything everywhere
all at once is
awesome tacular
[Applause]
just contemplating what the comments in
the other timeline where i said buy it
on blu-ray i wonder what they're saying
so everything everywhere all at once
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you